principalmente esto
trae una serie de ventaja positivas para
una serie de escenarios que hay dando
vuelta en la región no son como piezas
de un rompecabezas por ejemplo la
cuestión de la elección presidencial en
el Líbano es un tema que se puede poner
en la mesa de estos dos estas dos
potencias digamos regionales otro tema
también puede ser la cuestión en yemen
Seguramente se va a retomar
la cuestión entre los grupos palestinos
no con teniendo en cuenta la situación
actual que está viviéndose en Israel y
también todo el tema del programa
nuclear No no es que estas negociaciones
no existieran de hecho Irak estuvo Irak
estuvo justamente haciendo de alguna
manera de árbitro entre estas dos
potencias en los últimos dos años
tratando de que llegue a un acuerdo no
hubo éxito es decir el diálogo estaba lo
que pasa es que ahora claro el diálogo
se va a volver público este sujeto este
sujeto muy importante que además pone de
relieve el lugar que china está ganando
en la región en detrimento de la
potencia clásica la potencia global
clásica que estuvo presente en medio
oriente en las últimas décadas que fue
Estados Unidos